look at jose barrios
a little rough start his first timeout
was better last time didn't
really get a whole lot of run support
but to me against this uh
rather inexperienced pittsburgh lineup
they've got a few guys that have been
around so two down and now bell
hit 37 homers last year the bulk of
those came
from the left side gonzalez off the line
at third
and the one-two he got him strike three
at a poor cut from bell
95 up and away and burrill strikes out
two in a one two three first inning
joe musgrove we saw her timmy laudner
said earlier in the year he's never seen
a catcher with five fingers well
musgrove has six pitches so it's gonna
be a challenge for the catcher today but
everything cutter sinker four-seam
slider
he used quite effectively in his last
start
and a walk max kepler
draws the free pass first and third one
out and now rosario
and a base head to left through the open
side of the infield
crews will hold up at second and it
wasn't the prettiest thing in the world
but boy did it work
and the twins take a one-nothing lead
zario
smiling towards the twins dugout as he
was running up the first base line
lengthy inning for musgrove 21 pitches
one in two on still just won out
and now miguel cino that's a fair ball
over the bag
cruise around third he'll score rosario
to third he'll be held
and snow with another extra base hit
makes it two to nothing
well that's big for the twins and that's
big for him he's able to keep that ball
fair
it's a little fast ball right down the
middle doesn't try and do too much with
it pretty simple swing but
well clearly fair infield is in and
arise is the batter and now the 2-2
pitch a fly ball
center field deep dyson going back still
going still going and
makes the catch on the warning track
rosario tags and scores ceno makes third
and the twins have a three nothing lead
rbi number four
four at eyes and the twins indeed
capitalize on the gift
so now they're loaded up with one out
and that'll bring up gerard tyson
this will be his 40th pitch of the
afternoon
and there's the strikeout in 96.
the frustration in the broken bat two
and two the count on murphy
and here's the pitch he got him swinging
so barrios labors but
doesn't give up a single run he strikes
out three walks two pittsburgh strands
three twins coming up with a home second
back-to-back walks and musgrove in
trouble here oscar marin says to the
same thing pitching coaches out for the
second time and as many innings
and here comes nelson cruz 14 rbis tied
for the most
in the major leagues entering play today
and a chance to add on to it
with the bases loaded here in the second
three on
one out and the on one pitch line to
center field base it nelson cruz
byron is in kepler stops at third base
four nothing twins
and still one out and the bases remain
loaded
and the one-hole pitch ground ball right
side might be two at eyes glove second
one the return from marwin
end time double play four
five three inning ending double play so
runner at third one down and here's
polanco who walked in the second inning
and the 1-1 into the year to left and
deep down the line rosario into the
corner and fair territory will make the
catch reynolds will tag rosario was
moving away from the play and so that's
a sac fly for polanco and the pirates
have one on the board it's four to one
and here's danger in the box right now
that's nelson cruz
two hits two rbis he's scored once
and another single kepler held at third
and are loaded up now with one down
here's rosario against howard with the
bases loaded and one out
two and one to rosario toward the hole
and bleeds through
and it will score one
but not two great throw from the left
fielder reynolds
kepler scores polanco was thrown out
yeah he made a real nice play on a
diving play on a ball last night today
he charges this ball really well
with a lead you're gonna take a chance
and send some runners ball not hit
terribly hard there's a drone over the
field
i see it now it's actually inside the
ballpark and now it's
climbing over center field as it looks
well i have never experienced this
before in my life
like we don't have enough to worry about
in the bizarre 2020
world you just never know right missing
the outside corner some more hoops from
the
pirate dugout and they're loaded up now
with nobody out
fly ball right field
devises at they're gonna send him home
here's the throw and it's off target and
everybody moves up
well that's a fundamental error by
polanco
so a good job all the way around and now
you have two more guys in scoring
position and you're not in a double play
anymore
driven toward right center field
polanco's over he'll make the catch
again
and coming in from third base
the ball rolling free will be no advance
by avila but gonzalez comes in from
third base on another sacrifice slot
three hits in the inning here evans with
two singles a strikeout in the fly ball
evans lines this toward left field and
over the head of rosario murphy will
score phillip evans continues to hit
and now moran the last hope for
pittsburgh who was over three a walk
ran five home runs entering play today
only aaron judge with moore
popped up near the pirate dugout
gonzalez
shading his eyes and making the catch he
and navila collide
both players are okay and the twins
finish a phenomenal home stand